MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
a lot the Cloud can
offer on top of traditional
public sector solutions.
Join us in historic
downtown Austin, Texas,
as we talk to SADA Systems about
how the Cloud enables building
solutions like Atom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What does Atom do?
JOHN BIESAK: So Atom
is a lot more robust.
So in almost the opposite of
how dot maps is very niche
and kind of has its need and
things that it can address.
Atom is going to support
a lot broader, I guess,
use case within the DOT.
You've got things like asset
management and maintenance
management, work order
distribution, mobile data
collection.
These are going to
be the core use cases
that Atom kind of supports.
Some of our main use
cases that we'll tackle
are like bridge and
infrastructure management.
So a lot of the states and
counties in the United States
they have a budget every year.
They need to essentially upkeep
the bridges and the roads
and the signs and signals
in inefficient way.
They have an X amount of
money that they need to spend,
and they want to track
that kind of whole dollar
amount against the work that
they're sending out there.
And obviously, when you're
getting into the management
and upkeep of
infrastructure, especially
at the bridge and highway level,
safety is a huge concern here.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So streamlining these
workflows so people
don't have to jump
through a bunch of hoops
to do what they need to
do on an everyday basis.
JOHN BIESAK: Correct.
Yeah, it's all about--
and again, this
is kind of piggybacking
on that bringing material
design and that
ease of use, but we
want to make sure
we cater to all ends
of the spectrum within the DOT.
In the DOT you've got folks that
are very day-to-day users that
are going to be just querying
for very simple things, project
details, project managers
on a specific project.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So from
a technical perspective,
what does Atom look like?
JOHN BIESAK: Atom essentially
is a cloud-based solution,
and we're obviously leveraging
Google Cloud for that.
It allows us to do
some things feature
and functionality wise
that I don't think
has been quite possible
within the DOT space
up to this point, things
like offline access,
full native offline access for
our mobile users in the field.
Atom has a fully native iOS
and Android application.
And when you're working
with states that are just
more rural use cases and
assets in more rural areas,
you tend to have a problem where
they can't access their asset
information that they need,
forms, directions, all
those types of things.
And having the ability to cache
that data locally on the device
and push it to the Cloud after
they complete what they need
to do has been something
that we've received
a lot of positive feedback on.
Again, some of these states
have very rural areas
where users are going
out there in the field
and they need to have
access to asset information,
they need to have access to
the important information
that they need to do their
job out in the field.
So I think that's a crucial
part in leveraging Google Cloud.
And really taking that burden
of infrastructure management
away from the DOT,
I think is massive.
For them to have to
pay to do server manage
upkeep and things
like that, I think
those days are behind them.
And I think, because of
Google Cloud's capabilities
and the security requirements
that they're getting up to,
the DOT has no reason not to
go on Google Cloud or a cloud
provider.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So for a
group that wants to adopt Atom,
what does that look
like in comparison
to their existing workflows?
JOHN BIESAK: Yeah, so
that's a great point.
I think a lot of vendors
make a mistake where
they want to come in and totally
reinvent what cities are doing
and states are doing from
a workflow perspective.
In reality, the states have
been ironing out these processes
for 20, 30 years.
You've got folks within the
government that have been there
for 20, 30 years.
So if you try to come in
there and totally change
what they're doing,
fundamentally, you're
going to get pushback.
I mean, you're just going to.
There's folks within
the government that
have been there a
long time and are
used to a certain workflow
and a certain process.
And I think it's really crucial
that you get those adoption
rates high quickly to make
sure that you have success
within the government
with your product.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And all of this
is possible because
of the Cloud?
JOHN BIESAK: Yeah, 100%.
I think that the Cloud
allows for really high level
collaboration
between these groups.
Again, once you can get
that data to a point
where it's all sanitized
across these groups,
you can really start sharing and
doing that cross-asset analysis
that I think all
states want to get to.
It's a process for
them, but the Cloud
is for sure a way
that that's going
to enable them to be successful
and to actually start sharing
that data across departments.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, John, thank
you so much for coming
in and getting us
more about public
sector in the Cloud.
JOHN BIESAK: Yeah,
appreciate your time.
Thanks so much.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks for watching,
and stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we dive into the technical
side of dot maps.